[inaudible]
joining me today is a lawyer,
a gun rights activists in the host of know are on NRA TV.
Colia no,
are welcome to the Rubin report.
How's it going man?
How's it going?
My friends going good.
It's good to be in la.
I am a,
I'm glad to have you on.
We've been trying to do this for about a year.
Yeah,
you're a busy man.
I just don't like to think so.
It might just be a facade.
I put it on to avoid people but knowing actually,
but in reality now it's,
it's been,
it's been a pretty busy year.
Yeah.
Like extremely so.
And it doesn't ever seem to slow up and just want to think it does.
Something else jumps off well,
if you think coming on this show is going to help slow it down.
You are sorely mistaken.
Yeah.
Well I'm a bit of a masochist in that regards,
so we'll see.
We'll see.
By the time this hour he's done work sort of on earth.
Hell,
we can really shine you.
I'm pretty sure there will be some.
Yeah.
Well,
don't worry because there will be equal amounts on me just for sitting here with
you.
That's the interesting thing.
You know,
it's,
I don't want to say I've been blind to it,
but just being,
just seeing some of the reactions and responses that I got,
especially like for instance,
when I was on Mar,
when I,
after I did Bill Maher,
you know,
I saw some of the comments from the other side just for ease of communication.
But for people who normally don't agree with me and his audience,
they were like,
oh,
why would you have the NRA guy on there?
Even a,
it was a tweet I responded to yesterday and even though I was on my no tweeting
deal that I like to put myself on because so toxic in there sometimes.
How often do you do that?
Every 30 minutes.
I'm trying to do weekends disappearing at all of August.
Uh,
see it man.
Twitter's toxic man.
When you're in the lane that you and I are in,
it's toxic man.
And he can really,
even though you don't think you're taking that in,
even when you just kind of scrolling through,
you're taking it in.
Yeah.
You know,
and it's like a constantly up develop as this pattern of just,
yeah,
don't respond to that because they're baiting you.
I mean,
and things of that nature.
But,
um,
I,
I saw a tweet and she's like,
yeah,
I love Phil Mar.
Oh,
I love this episode,
but you have that in Ira guy on there.
And I'm like,
Jesus,
are we not allowed to have discourse anymore if it,
especially if the disagrees with something that you believe in.
Uh,
and you know,
and I was like,
this is a very dangerous road we're going down.
If that's,
if that's going to be the case because you forget,
you know,
we live in this country together and we're not all the same.
There's about 350 million of it.
Yeah.
We might not all think the same thing.
Exactly.
Pretty crazy.
It's,
it's ton of sense.
It,
at least for me,
it's a little disheartening.
Um,
because I grew up under the guise and understanding the importance of discourse
and being able to talk things out,
even if you do disagree with someone,
but then even still having the ability to set aside whatever views I may have on
a particular issue and then be able to speak with you cordially or have respect
for you even though we don't agree that's the way I was brought up.
And so to see the country kind of falling into this ink extremely Detroit like
divisiveness,
it,
it's,
it's a,
it's an,
yeah.
You know,
I don't want to know me and get all emo on you,
but it does,
it was like we don't have the guest cry until the end,
but we can do it this way.
But that's exactly why I wanted to have you on because you are okay going into
enemy territory.
I'm not calling this enemy territory,
but you did.
You did marsh show where you knew a certain percentage of the audience was just
going to hate you.
And we talked about it briefly right before we started,
but you found mar to be basically pretty,
pretty respected,
even yet open,
even though on policy you probably disagreements with you with 80,
80% of this.
Pretty much.
Yeah.
And you know,
and it was something that I ended up perspecting about him in that regard.
Cause like I said,
I kind of,
I went in prepared for war.
I didn't go into do war,
but I went and prepared for it.
You know,
it was like prepare for the worst hope for the best.
Um,
and I'd say I got the best in a sense of it was,
uh,
it was a discourse where he challenged me,
but it wasn't this kind of
tumultuous kind of butting of the heads where would just turn into something
that was just ugly.
Well,
he wasn't trying to get yet.
Try to understand you cause that,
that,
you know,
I'm trying to do that here.
I think there's a couple of other places where people are trying to do that.
But yeah,
that's the thing that's been good lost.
And that's an interesting thing you pointed out there.
It's,
I think sometimes people take offense to that idea.
It's like,
well,
I don't want your intruder intriguing.
I think in tree kind of offense people sometimes because it's like we all grow
up with a typical understanding of what we expect certain people to be like.
And then when certain things don't fit,
it's like,
hmm,
that's interesting.
How did you get there?
Right.
And I don't,
I think when it's innocent like that,
I don't think there's an issue there.
When you use it to try to kind of muscle people into believing a certain thing
based on what they are,
then that's when we start having problems.
You know what I mean?
It's like you see me,
it's like,
how do you,
as a black guy that happened to me when I first started doing what I did with
the NRA,
um,
uh,
Russell Simmons are,
and I'll never forget this.
I was like,
I was like in Virginia Beach,
I think.
Um,
and Russell said,
Aye.
Aye did my first sets of videos rolled out with the NRA and I get this tweet
from Russell Simmons and he's like,
how can you as a young black man pushed daddy you,
you know,
the typical rhetoric in that regard,
even though he often is all about trying to get people to,
exactly.
Which was a really,
yeah.
And so I,
you know,
I responded,
I said,
you know,
like I didn't know advocating for self defense and self reliance was a bad
thing.
I didn't know that only non black people were allowed to do that.
You know what,
I'm right.
And so that was kind of like my first foray into that world of wait a minute,
people have an expectation of me based on my race that I'm not going to say I
was oblivious to,
but it just,
when it was coming from people that look like me as well with the same level of
intensity,
that's when I go,
wow.
Okay.
All right.
So here,
that's what this is.
Yeah.
So I wanna I wanna back up to a little bit of childhood and growing up cause
your evolutions,
conditioning.
But Let,
let's just say with this for one second because I think there's something really
interesting about that thing right there that often if you listen to the media,
they'll you that that police are hunting down black men and all of this and then
at the same time you're saying,
well,
we should be able to arm ourselves and protect ourselves from the white
supremacists to whoever,
whoever doing that,
but meaning that lawfully and legally we should be able to take care of
ourselves.
If you believe that the system is so corrupt and the police are so corrupt and
there's racists running around everywhere,
you're trying to bring the power back to yourself.
That's to me that's very empowering.
Yet somehow this seemingly is lost when this conversation hits the mainstream.
It's amazing.
I don't understand it.
It's like in one breath you're talking about let's,
let's take the current administration for instance,
like don't paint it as this the most vicious and valving on the planet,
and then it's like,
well then let's give the same guns that you have for your own self reliance.
I would you would use to protect yourself against this monster that you've said
existed and let's give it to them and then place your entire alliance.
And with respect to your safety on the same people you,
I,
you're telling me I should be scared of it doesn't look horrible.
Give him your weapons.
What again,
just it's,
it's mindblowing.
Right?
And so what it does though,
it exposes this notion that the,
there's an absence of ability to,
I don't want to say by ability or people just choosing not to critically think.
And we're at a point now where we have access and I tell people,
it's like,
it amazes me some of the questions that I get.
And it's like you literally have a device that gives you access to all of the
information in the world and it's in your pocket.
And in the case of my overabundant tasks,
I have two of them.
Right?
And it's like,
it takes you right into phones.
You,
I assume you have like eight guns on you at all.
You write those rifles,
some here,
so.
Right.
You know,
and it's,
it's amazing how when we have such access to so much information,
we've become so lazy at reaching for it.
This was almost like back in the day when we didn't have this access,
we were more adamant about search searching and seeking it out and critically
thinking about things.
It's almost,
we become too fast for our own good.
Right.
So the obsession now is instant information,
instant information regardless of whether or not the information is of any use
or good or if or if that's even correct.
Yeah.
You know,
and so it's,
I hate it cause you know,
I,
I blogged,
I've done all of those things and actually get people to get mad at me when I
don't jump on a certain issue quick enough.
And when I say Cook enough within 30 seconds,
the second I'll see that sometimes then goes down in the news and uh,
literally two minutes go by or I'm at dinner and I wasn't looking at my phone
and then I'll get a slew of tweets.
People,
wow,
I see you didn't comment on that.
You must be an article.
Could God paid off,
God forbid it involves a black person and there's a gun within 10 miles,
I have to jump on it.
Yeah.
You know,
and,
and there are some cases,
I understand there are some people who do,
who are just now getting into this who are just now getting into firearms and
they are black.
Right.
And you know,
they look to me for understanding and direction cause I've been doing it for so
long so that I understand.
Um,
but,
but other people,
it's just this constant desire to be like,
Aha,
I got you.
I knew you were Kuhn kind of deal.
Right.
And it's like,
like give me 30 seconds to even read the article you just sent me 10 seconds
ago.
Right.
And then from there,
and then not to mention,
you know,
there's a thing called work that I do.
So yeah,
I'm still doing that as well.
So I'm,
you know,
I'm juggling a lot of things.
I don't have to tell you,
you probably have to be 10 more articles to even ascertain anything close to the
truth.
Bingo.
And that's the one thing that I,
a lot,
I think a lot of people don't do.
And I almost tweeted that the other day.
I go,
you know,
it's very dangerous to read headlines,
especially in the day and age of clickbait titles,
to just read headlines and then make an opinion based off of that or think you
know and understand what happened at a particular story.
Because there are so many articles that I've read about me and what I've said
where the headline said one thing and to cover their asses within the article,
they'll clarify exactly what they,
what it is that I said,
but they're banking on the idea that people were just going to read the
headlines and then run with that.
And so it ends up making a fool of you.
I'm full of people.
Well what's your personal policy on that?
About how to respond to that?
Do you go all in on the fight?
Do you and your it,
cause I,
this has happened to me in Rochester in the last week.
Daily be said.
I was all right.
Cheerleader that correct me if I'm wrong here.
You're black.
I think so.
How am I doing for the,
for an orange juice,
you suck.
No.
Well I mean,
but this is the level of pity.
But then it's about how much time do you want to invest in,
in defending yourself and by doing that defense,
do you just add intensity to the people going,
I see we can get them to defend himself.
And then before you know it,
your whole life is dedicated to defending yourself from fake attacks rather than
doing the work that you care about.
Well two things.
One,
they do it to you cause you're dangerous.
You're dangerous.
Not Because you agree with me in certain,
in certain issues,
you're dangerous in the fact that you're just simply willing to talk to me.
So for,
it's the same thing happen.
When I did,
I did the interview with killer Mike.
Right?
They jumped all over him.
Not because of what he said,
but just because he sat down and had the conversation with me half the time they
don't even listen.
Oh,
that's,
that's interesting.
Getting pointed out because I was talking to my friend,
I'm like,
how can anyone watch this interview and not walk away with saying,
you know,
that was a great conversation with two people who don't agree on everything,
but there's some things we were grilling is like,
cause they don't watch it.
That tells like,
what do you mean?
It's like I had this,
this weird blonde moment,
right?
Yeah.
I'm like,
what do you mean?
He's like,
they didn't watch it.
they don't actually watch the video.
They just read the title and then assume they know what happened in the video
and to make their opinion from there.
And I'm like,
damn,
you're right.
I hate going down in the weeds with too much in this because it feels like we're
just responding to all of the craziness.
But even in the,
even in like the youtube ecosystem.
Yeah.
When we put videos up,
sometimes within 10 seconds there's a hundred comments and that was an hour
away.
I want that time machine because I would be a lot more productive.
But it's always the haters that that's why I won't bring it up cause it,
cause then that hate is the thing that's always leading us.
And then I think that brings it back to where you started a moment ago,
which is that we're in this polarized thing and it's because the haters are,
are sort of paving the road and everyone else is just going down the road.
I think a few of us are actually trying to better road that more of us can get.
I,
the interesting thing about the discourse the way it is now,
right?
And so our politics have become our entertainment.
That's the one that's the dangerous aspect,
right?
So if it's not vitriolic,
if it's not snarky,
if it's not any of those things,
it people don't pay attention to it.
And I'm the biggest advocate of like,
all right,
look if you,
if you don't agree with me on something,
you don't have to be an ass about it right now.
Can I be snarky?
Hell yeah.
You know,
I,
I can absolutely be Saki,
but what I,
what I tried to do to respond to the initial question you asked me about how do
I,
like,
how do I go all in?
Do I respond?
So like for instance,
on Twitter,
what I've kind of held myself back to doing now is if I can tell that the person
is literally seeking out an answer or response,
that's I'm going to give them that same energy in terms of,
okay,
no,
let's,
let's have that conversation.
Right?
Because there was a point in time where everything I responded to when I respond
to it through the lens of just being this snarky as,
you know what I mean?
And Yeah,
sure.
It was,
I entertaining myself.
Absolutely.
But then I had to ask myself,
was I really moving and conversation and the dialogue along,
even though it is Twitter,
it's Twitter,
it's a dumpster fire,
right?
But what I started,
it has some importance,
does just the truth.
That's why it keeps coming up in so many of these conversations.
We've got high level people with great minds that are open and engaging,
that are still involved in the stupidity of that.
So it's like,
I always feel guilty when I bring it up with the guests more.
It's like,
I don't want to touch that thing again.
And then on the other hand,
we all know it's real.
You know,
it just,
it just is whether we want it to be or not.
Like you said,
whether we like,
Nah,
this the meeting of expression right now.
Um,
and so we have to,
if they're,
you know,
just like either adapt or die,
but you know,
it's,
I try,
I try to be what it is.
I tried to be the opposite of what I complain about.
At least I try in terms of like,
sometimes I'll see snarky messages and then I'll respond by trying to be
reasonable.
I say,
okay,
I get it.
You don't like me but answer this question for me.
And I tried to move the dialogue along.
No,
it isn't happening to,
it gets deleted.
Yeah.
Almost every single time.
The second you shed a little light on it.
Grad scatter.
Yup.
What is the,
uh,
before we dive too much into your past,
what is the thing that they're criticizing you most for?
Like you come across to me as a pretty rational,
decent open guy.
You're trying to empower yourself.
Okay.
So what is it that they're always going after you?
Is it that thing that the black men shouldn't be for guns?
I mean,
is it that simply stupid?
So I'm like,
so I don't,
I'm not gonna be so naive as to assume it's simply just because I'm black and
I'm in the guns.
They are already thinking holds up.
That's part of it.
That's a big part of it is just aligning myself in the organization that they
seemingly,
that they see as being a racist organization that hates black people.
Okay.
We're going to talk plenty about the NRA,
right?
So there's that element of it.
But then there's,
there is also this idea that being a young black man,
that I am supposed to run from guns because of the projected image that we've
all had forced down our throats with respect to black men in firearms in this
country for decades.
You know,
black man with a gun,
he's a thug,
he's a drug dealers and gang banger period.
So now when I,
um,
young attorney educated,
open minded and you know,
with respect to different issues and then I'm pushing the narrative of the
second amendment,
it sets off an explosive level of cognitive dissonance.
And people who have what I love this quote and I believe was Bush who said it,
the soft bigotry of low expectations,
right?
And it,
they hate it.
They hate it the same way they hate you now because you can't control someone
who's willing to think independently outside of what a stereotypically expected
of you.
Right?
Um,
and that's what the lady was coming in.
And so it was like,
Yo,
do progressive,
you're liberal,
you know,
so,
so for tone,
but you still have that ability to step outside of that and say,
you know what?
Let me let me,
okay,
I can see that perspective.
That's dangerous for people who want to control people.
So when I want to control the way you think,
the way you see yourself,
I cannot allow you to develop it and ability to think independently on separate
issues because then I can't control you.
So if I,
if I say,
you know what,
I can do everything for you depend on me.
The last thing I want you to do and understand is,
you know what?
Wait a minute.
You mean to tell me I could protect myself?
You mean to tell me I don't have to depend on calling a cop in order to come
save me if someone does try to break into my house because then I can't control
you.
I can't own your vote because what the gun has done for me and a lot of people,
it serves as a catalyst for the awakening of a lot of people don't understand.
You know what,
I can do more for myself than I realize,
you know?
And once that,
once that spark is set off than a lot of things,
you start to realize,
you know,
I don't,
what maybe,
you know,
not on,
I'm holding myself to a different level of accountability.
Maybe I might try to do this on my own,
you know,
it doesn't just feel good.
I mean,
putting aside,
I know a lot of people are into facts over feelings these days,
right?
Shapiro but doesn't that statement right there that that you can do more for
yourself?
It just feels good.
It feels amazing.
Some power back to yourself and going the government or you,
whoever you are that are not in charge of of my life,
my responsibility,
my livelihood,
and my family.
The rest of it,
it's the most invigorating feeling in the world.
And I'm with you.
I'm all about facts,
feelings,
and I'm mean it from the standpoint,
I don't allow my feelings to dictate the facts,
you know,
I do think feelings are necessary,
right?
Cause we,
cause within the absence of them,
we just become cold,
calculated creatures,
right.
And we are still human.
We are,
you know what I mean?
So it's like now at least,
right.
So,
you know,
when I talk about the issue of firearms,
I do actively try to inquire.
I was,
I was having a discussion with a lady not too long ago about just general
firearm issues with respect to her son,
right?
Who's young,
black man.
And I asked her,
you know,
like,
are you fearful of the idea of him carrying a gun and so forth and so on.
And I have to bring myself back when I'm having a discussion with someone like
that because I don't have kids.
Right.
So yeah.
And my godfather that,
yeah.
So,
and,
and I,
and I love her,
but it's not the same for a woman who has a son.
So I have to be cognizant of that and understand what goes into that.
When she's thinking about whether or not she,
he,
she's okay with him owning a firearm.
And,
and then on top of that,
having this idea that her son is more likely to get killed by a cop because he
has a gun on him versus when he doesn't,
you know,
and that's where the feeling component comes in where it's necessary.
I think you,
if you can't sympathize with that,
then it makes you dismissive.
And so then that person can't relate to you,
then we can have that conversation.
You know what I mean?
And that comes from personal experience.
Absolutely.
Cause,
uh,
when I was reading your bio there,
I mean,
it's really interesting stuff about how you evolved sort of politically and
personally,
but when you started getting into guns,
you kind of hide,
had to hide it from your mom either.
So everyone actually a little bit about growing up and then sort of your kind of
politics and then how do we have,
we gotcha.
So I've,
I grew up largely a closet anti gunner.
I didn't realize I was,
I gonna to the wall.
There was one present,
right?
I wasn't kind of rapidly running out,
running out,
screaming,
I hate guns or anything like that.
But when a woman was president,
I remember there's one moment,
um,
when I was in college,
I had a roommate,
um,
one of her friends brought a gun over.
I was like,
you need to get the hell on my part.
You can get the hell out of my,
out of my apartment.
And,
um,
had a good friend of mine who randomly just asked me,
hey,
do you want to go to the range?
Never even thought about it and ever even crossed my mind,
which is how I know a lot of times I can decipher based on certain comments
whether or not somebody is actually coming from a place of ignorance or place of
understanding.
Because I was at guy never even thought about going to raise,
never thought about shooting gun,
but could tell you all the opinions in the worldwide.
And like,
right.
And so when I hear that rhetoric now,
I can usually point it out and I'm like,
you've never shopped before.
You've never even held a gun before.
And so from that perspective,
we went to the gun range and a shot for the first time and I was hooked.
Now I was hooked,
not from a political standpoint now,
not even from an empowering,
oh my God,
I can protect myself now standpoint,
it was just pure fascination with the mechanics,
the physics,
all of it.
Um,
I'm very kind of like curious mind.
So for me it was like kind of like this,
like the idea that I'm launching a project out faster than the speed of sound
and a little target,
like hundreds of yards away.
Like that was awesome.
So first shy,
you were hooked.
First shot,
terrified the second side.
So it was like 11 for love,
his second shot.
Right,
right.
Um,
so from that perspective after,
so after that,
I just,
I follow that rabbit all the way down the hall,
but it was,
like I said,
it was more from a scientific,
mechanical understanding of it.
Then as time went on,
then I started looking at it from more intellectual,
second amendment,
political activist standpoint.
And then I started my,
then the lawyer mind kicked in and they,
and I started looking at,
I'm like,
I'm hearing something.
Then we,
cause we,
during the time period,
that particular time period we had a couple of pretty big mass shootings that
happened and so I started paying it then.
So I'm now,
I'm paying attention more to this kind of like when you're thinking about buying
a car and you never see it on the road.
And then once you start thinking about buying you see it everywhere.
That was pretty much what happened now.
So I'm like,
I'm hearing the conversation about guns everywhere now and I'm like none of this
is making any sense logically.
Like what people are proposing.
It doesn't,
it was so pure,
it wasn't like an agenda driven.
It's like this doesn't make sense to me.
It's like a window.
Like a sticker on the window is not going to stop somebody from bringing a gun
in there saying that it's illegal.
You mean the sign that says [inaudible] not going to read the sign and be like,
oh exactly right.
So that's Kinda when I started jumping into the more activist advocate side of
things.
Um,
with respect to the second amendment.
Yeah.
And when you first got guns,
yeah.
You were literally hiding them.
I was from your mind.
Cause cause,
cause she was very much let me,
she was a single parent mom raising a black son.
She wanted to port every stereotype on the planet.
Right.
My mom over compensated with me tremendously because she under,
she understood in her mind the limitations that come with being a woman,
raising a man by herself.
So she overcompensated.
So where it's like usually typically have like mama's boys who were just kind of
like,
mom does everything for her.
She can do shit.
She was just like,
go wash your own clothes,
come here and go do everything.
She made me and I,
at the time I just thought she was just being a mean mom.
Right.
Not Realizing,
you know,
it was her overcompensating from the standpoint of like,
I gotta make this dude,
I gotta raise a man.
Right.
And so,
but so she was trying to buck.
So I knew once I started getting into guns,
no,
no.
Because the perception was black man with gun gang banger.
Right.
And you know,
she had some insecurities and that she was like,
you know,
like they're going to come a point where I'm not going to be to control this
kid.
I don't know what it's going to be doing.
And so I didn't want to terrify her and make her think that I was living some of
the Ferriss lifestyle that she,
and it was almost in a way to protect her more than was to hide it from my side
because I didn't want her to feel like she,
like she failed as a mother.
And so I knew if she saw the AK 47 that I had hidden under my bed,
in her mind,
she knows about guns.
All she knows is what she sees in the media.
And we all were like we had touched upon before,
that imagery is not positive.
So she comes home,
sees AK 47 in the bed.
She's like,
oh my God,
my son is a gang banger first to sit under the bed.
I said in the bed.
Is there anything you want to tell me here?
We talk about that later.
[inaudible] I already bought it as I did this kind of embarrassing because you
know both basketball fans,
I used to sleep with my basketball.
Oh yeah.
Oh Man.
Yeah,
ball was life.
That was everything.
Now you've still got any skills?
I don't know some,
some,
yeah,
I think that was something.
So I'm actually working on trying to for the next NRA annual meetings put
together like a to a charity.
Basketball on it.
If you're down.
Can I get in on that?
Let's do it.
All right,
let's do it.
But,
uh,
I've never slept with my guns though.
That was an odd phrase.
All right.
Okay.
So,
so from that point when you started getting okay with this and now you're
exploring it,
as you said intellectually,
yeah.
How long before you were really an advocate for this stuff because you always
sort of wanted to fight for something.
Yes.
The theme with you,
he was deaf.
That that's what I wanted to do.
I wanted to be an advocate.
I wanted to be in the courtroom defending people.
That's,
that was my goal.
Like even to the detriment of my grades.
Like I focused more on like my mock trial stuff when I was in law school.
Then I did my actual work,
like the like schoolwise right.
And um,
I liked being divorced for people.
I like being able to speak to people who can articulate certain things away that
maybe I can,
and I never saw this cold going your way that it did,
but I'm doing exactly what I always wanted to do.
And,
and for me with the gun thing,
I remember being in like I'd be in like class in law school and the way that
they,
like the seats are staggered.
They're like stadium seats,
right?
So if I'm on my computer and you're behind me,
you can see what I'm doing on my computer.
And like I'd be in class and like,
um,
research and guns and stuff like that.
Right.
And Yeah,
all man.
Oh Dude,
like people.
And the thing is,
a lot of things that were being said about me I didn't even know about till
later on.
People were concerned.
Yeah.
Like really?
Like Yo,
it's like,
yeah,
he's like disease.
He's straight.
He's not doing anything crazy.
He's not,
you know,
um,
and uh,
I get it if you don't,
if you're not into that kind of thing,
um,
and you don't follow it,
the idea of how being passionate about something you perceive to be,
uh,
a tool that used for killing people and only killing people.
It's going to seem a little odd to you.
But because I came to it so naturally,
so organically without any of that,
it just made sense in my mind.
I was so unapologetic about it once I got over being apologetic about it,
that I didn't push it in people's faces.
But you know,
there was a,
there was even a time,
like that's how my Instagram got started was me separating.
So the people who followed me up until that point,
you know,
I had a girlfriend at the time,
it was like,
you know,
we get a lot of questions from people,
kind of tone down the gun stuff a little bit.
Um,
and it was,
it was kind of an innocent,
you know,
thing.
But I never really,
I just said,
you know,
forget it.
I'm just going to set up a whole nother page and I'm just going to do all the
gun stuff I want to do on that page.
Yeah.
Um,
and then now that's taken over.
I have,
I don't even use the other one.
I don't even know if I remember the password,
but it,
and so from there,
that's where things really started taking off.
And then with the in,
and then when I started,
because I started doing gun reviews.
And so then from there when I got into the political component of it,
then I started talking to doing my commentary,
and then that's when things started really taking off.
Oh.